solve and eliminate any extraneous
solutions and what they mean by
extraneous solutions are in the course
of solving this this rational equation
right here we might get some solutions
that if we actually put it into the
original into the original problem would
give us undefined expressions and so
those solutions are extraneous solutions
they actually don't apply yet you want
to throw them out and so let's look at
this equation we have x squared over x
plus 2 is equal to 4 over x plus 2. so
right out of the right from the get go
we don't know if this is going to
necessarily be a solution to this
equation but we know just looking at
this that if x is equal to negative 2
then this denominator and this
denominator are going to be 0 and you're
dividing by 0 it would be undefined so
we can right from the get go exclude x
is equal to negative 2. so x cannot be
equal to negative 2. that would make
either of these expressions undefined on
either side of the equation so with that
out of the way let's try to solve it so
as a first step we want to get the x
plus 2 out of the denominator so let's
multiply both sides by x plus 2
x plus 2 x plus 2 divided by x plus 2 is
just 1. and we can assume that that
their x plus 2 isn't zero so it's going
to be defined x plus 2 divided by x plus
2 is just 1. and so our equation has
simplified to
x squared
x squared is equal to 4 and you could
probably do this in your head but i want
to do it properly so you can write this
you could subtract 4 from both sides do
it in kind of the proper quadratic
equation form so x squared minus 4 is
equal to 0. i just subtracted 4 from
both sides over here
and so you can factor this this is a
difference of squares you get x plus 2
times x minus 2 is equal to zero
and then if this is equal to zero if the
product of two things are equal to zero
that means either one or both of them
are equal to zero so this tells us that
x plus 2 is equal to 0 or
x minus 2 is equal to 0.
if you subtract 2 from both sides of
this equation right here you get x is
equal to negative 2. if you add 2 to
both sides of this equation right over
here you get x is equal to 2.
and we're saying that
either of these would make this last
expression 0. now we know that we need
to exclude one of them we know that x
cannot be equal to negative two so x
equals negative two is an extraneous
solution
extraneous solution it's not really a
solution for it is a solution for this
once we got rid of the rational
expressions but it's not a solution for
this original problem up here because it
would make the expressions undefined it
would cause you to divide by zero so the
only solution here is x is equal to two
and you can check it yourself you do two
squared you get four over two plus two
is four and that should be equal to four
over two plus two over four which it
definitely does one is equal to one